in the movie people recognize you I love  this final movie when they recognize and  all the kids start singing happen does  that ever happen to you when big came  out my dad and my stepmom were in New  York we went to a really fancy  restaurant  there was a pianist and a harpist and a  violinist playing a little music and you  know the the piano dance in big was the  heart and soul well suddenly a piano and  a harp and a violin has started playing  hearty soul oh my god that was I said I  I think this is because this is because  of the move do you think it's cool it's  better than the other stuff you have a  problem you know I will not stop talking  until you subscribe to my youtube  channel that's right and I could talk a  lot seriously not gonna stop yep still  here not going anywhere I see you don't  walk away from this